[Music]
deb starts off this hour in des moines
iowa hi deb how are you
hi dave yes this is deb my husband and i
were basic followers of the dave ramsey
way
we always had one difference
he kept wanting in his 40s and 50s to
stock money away for retirement i wanted
to pay the mortgage off our mortgage was
at a very low rate
so he thought we'd be better off paying
the mortgage
and
earning that retirement money getting it
in those iras and stuff at
a higher interest rate
so my one concession was okay before you
retire then at age 60 and he retired at
62.
we're going to pay off that homework
home mortgage which we did
so he retired at 62
were you know
everyday millionaires
i'm going to retire this year at 63.
my 40-year-old son is getting married
for the first time
i told him and his fiancee my one regret
was we did not pay off our mortgage
sooner
and my son's coming back at me with that
same argument mom why would i pay off
the mortgage when i have a low interest
rate
if i can make more money putting
the money into
investment
so dave what
can i tell them
it's gonna be hard to convince him
against his will i mean you can give him
some tools resources has he is he does
he know about the ramsay plan
basically he does and beyond his home
mortgage he has no other debt okay yeah
we we hear this argument a lot and it
looks good on paper but we found that
when you actually do this stuff and when
you survey all these millionaires with
paid for homes
none of them are going you know what i
kind of miss my mortgage i want to go
back into debt and when he frees up that
mortgage payment guess what he can do
now invest way more than he was
so
for sure for sure okay does your husband
think that he is now an everyday
baby steps millionaire
because he
didn't pay off the house and invested
the money
does he think that's how he became a
millionaire
that's a good question i've never asked
him yeah
because i i think he would tell you
that's that's not how he became a
millionaire
the way he became a millionaire was he
steadily invested and he controlled his
expenses
and that enabled him to not only become
a millionaire but also pay off the house
which added to
the process
so the the answer to the question is
number one you're not going to tell a 40
year old anything
you know
he's going to do whatever he wants to do
so george is right my grandmother's
saying applies those convinced against
their will are of the same opinion still
if he actually does want to engage a
conversation which it doesn't sound like
he does it sounds like you do
but if he does except his girlfriend or
her fiance agreed she kind of took my
side
she did oh
okay so we're having a good healthy fun
family argument like the ramsays do
every meal okay yeah i probably do we
all argue with rachel about our
conspiracy theories at every meal so
okay
all right so um
you gotta have some fun right so uh
exactly well the answer to the question
or the answer to the argument is several
fold okay
um i i have approached it in my life
from about three or four different
angles and every one of those angles has
led me to pay off the house the first
angle i approached it from
once i went broke with borrowed money on
real estate
i i was a baby christian and i couldn't
find anything in the bible that said
anything good about debt you're a fool
you're a slave
um it's unwise it's not a salvation
issue spiritually and it's not a uh
it's um
certainly not even a sin
biblically but every mention of debt in
the bible is negative so as a person of
faith i had to say okay my heavenly
father says this is a dumb idea
biblically speaking dead is stupid okay
why would he say that because he loves
me if the best way to become wealthy is
to borrow on your house and then take
that money and invest it in the stock
market okay so that first step is i
entered it through that argument then
the next argument i entered into was
this idea of risk
debt
equals risk i think we can all agree to
that more debt equals more risk less
debt equals less risk no debt equals
virtually no risk
and so
and you can tell that by when you say
okay if borrowing against your house at
three percent or five percent and
investing it in the market in a mutual
fund a ten percent rate of return 12
rate of return whatever i'm making that
spread
if that is an accurate mathematical
formula why would you not
borrow
300 000 on a 100 000 house you would
borrow all you can up to your eyeballs
if you're always going to make
a seven or an eight percent spread right
right but when you ask somebody well why
don't you borrow two million dollars
that way then that put that puts them in
freak out mode because when you put the
absurd on the table no way it makes your
emotions kick in and your emotions are
where you experience risk not in your
intellect
so your heart is where you feel risk
your head is where you do math
and so your heart goes your heart starts
beating like oh god no
well that's because now suddenly you're
equating risk with debt and in his
discussion he's got the debt small
enough in his mind that he doesn't
equate it to risk follow me
right so
all of that to say that in sophisticated
financial circles which your son doesn't
run in
they we actually are taught to adjust a
risky investment
with an unrisky investment or low risk
investment with a high risk investment
was actually a mathematical process for
adjusting those two for risk to where
you can compare them apples to apples so
the high risk investment after adjusted
for risk the rate of return would come
down the low risk investment after
adjusted for risk would come up and then
you could compare them apples to apples
and there's just a statistical measure
of risk called a beta which is the
measure of the hill in the valley and
the frequency of the hill in the valley
and when you put it on a chart that's
measures risk
if you entered that and you actually
used a real math formula for your your
son's
naive math formula that's incorrect
then you said okay we're taking on more
risks so we can't really count the
entire spread
from the mortgage rate up to the market
rate as spread because we have to adjust
for risk and we adjust for risk it
neutralizes the benefit of the borrowed
money
there's your academic answer
i gave you a spiritual answer academic
answer okay now let me give you one more
the borrower's slave to the lender
so that must mean
slaves think differently
they have different relationships
because they're not in control of their
lives they keep a job they wouldn't keep
otherwise i can't quit this job i have a
house payment i can't tell the boss to
take this job and shove it
in a toxic low integrity situation
i have to keep the job because i have a
house payment so you keep a bad job with
a bad boss
until it ends up quite caving in on your
head and you end up making less in your
life
because you're forced into stuff
like slaves are
you make more money you have better
relationships you take less risk and you
make money faster if you don't have a
mortgage your son is so wrong it's
unbelievable